this is the big joke this is the this is
the danger miss me loud humming tada
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
to another episode of the Dean show in
this show we're going to dedicate this
to our new brothers in faith people that
have acknowledged what's in their very
nature that there is a creator and he's
one and alone worthy of worship I'm not
going to worship His creation and what
entails his creation a man a woman the
Sun the Moon anything that was created
ahead of beginning is not the Creator
that's his creation I'm not going to
submit I'm not going to worship his
courage I'm going to worship the creek
tour and I'm going to follow the example
of his last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him the same way you would have
followed Jesus Moses Abraham if you were
living during their time you declare
that there's none worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth and everything we say Allah and
Muhammad peace be upon him is his
messenger and now you're our brother in
faith you're a Muslim and we want to
give some beautiful advice to you
because you have made the best decision
in your life and we're going to come
back with dr. Sheikh will leave a Sunni
so we can get some more examples on how
you can stay on this way be firm on this
way and die on this way the same way of
life is all the message of God and then
you can attain the best reward peace and
happiness in this life and paradise in
the next we'll be right back this is the
theme to this is the days the theme jus
this is the name this is the theme this
is the main you this is the beach not
making peace be unto you are they comes
an hour at the level of care how are you
sure very good pretty good from girl
thank you very much for finding the time
to be with us we know you the vice
president of l- you're the imam of the
Clear Lake Islamic Center very busy very
busy and I'm honored that you find the
time to be with us here in the D show
I'm the one is honored by being here and
I really appreciate inviting me again to
your show masha'Allah please send salam
who sent salaams to your family who's
out there and all the muslims and this
is for the new Muslims and we started
with the greeting of peace and why I
emphasize this because if I'm wrong
correct me this is a greeting of all the
messages of God and all the messengers
of God were Muslim and they did islam so
the people they got through all the
false propaganda and all this you know
baloney that's attributed with Islam and
they did was in their very nature they
submitted to the one guy they're doing
Islam now they're Muslim what advice do
we have for them share first all praise
due to Allah in his praise and blessings
and peace be upon our prophet Mohamed
Salah asylum and all the prophets and
messengers and their followers let me
start by saying congratulation and male
hospital except from you it's a
wonderful thing it's a great decision
that you have made to accept a lot to be
your God and basically the only one that
you submit your soul to and each is
mohamed salah salem to be your messenger
I by doing this you're just accepting
all the messengers and all the prophets
that Allah have sent before and as you
just said it's the just a greeting show
you it is we're just the natural
extension of all these prophets a
messenger that Allah sent them to
humanity through history for those
brothers and sisters who became Muslim I
would like to say first of all almost
thank Allah for this great
blessings because this is the greatest
blessing that I lost my that I can give
it to anyone this is the best nima the
best blessing that he can bestowed upon
anyone so thank and be grateful to him
thank him all the time don't ever quit
doing that that that's that's one thing
and the second thing I would say to
those brothers and sisters lehren your
religion this religion is based on
knowledge it's very interesting it's
just not an empty emotions it's based on
knowledge and understanding and this
knowledge is not going to be acquired by
anything by to dedicate part of your
time to learn the D to learn the
religion this knowledge is not going to
come by just feelings or just by dreams
that you see in your in your while it's
leaving and you became a spiritually
motivated do this of that no it's logic
it you need to pray how can i pray i
need to say certain things a prayer what
i'm going to say there is a quran there
is the prayer that you do every day that
is things you say when you get to the
house and you get out of that you need
to learn so many things is based on
knowledge and if this been said that
leads me to the third advice which is
this religion is so deep so white the
Prophet SAW solemn said no one can ever
yeah any compete with this religion
think that an overnight our wall cover
all aspects i get everything in it no so
he said 40 louie beautiful yeah any take
it step by step graduate and be easy
don't basically try to how to think that
i'm going to learn everything in one day
or one month or one year we are on a
process of learning that's why this
religion i always say when it comes to
offering good deeds to the worship of
allah there is no maximum there is
minimum but there is no maximum that so
make sure that you know what are the
minimum that is required from you as a
Muslim let's say for example you pray
the five-time prayer and Ramadan comes
you fast and basically you know how to
perform the salat how you perform there
so yeah there's a cat and the head
in your lifetime whenever you are
capable of making it the five pillars
then these pillars when you have it we
have it strong when you have it built
you build on it otherwise why it's
pillar it's not pillar just to be have
you ever seen a building has five
pillars and that's it it's a structure
to build on it so that's where the other
things comes you build on it basically
other things that you you need to add to
it later on so basically one be grateful
thankful to Allah to learn your Dean
three take it graduate step-by-step be
easy don't rush to do everything at one
and the last thing I would cite that
basically this religion guide us to the
best of manners this religion guide us
to this is very important aspect in this
religion the spiritual aspect of it and
a concept of mannerism and ethics you're
a man will not be complete without this
aspect when you spiritually pure when
you are and this nothing can purify you
like avoiding the indecent act avoiding
the sins and at the same time to
beautify yourself with these beautiful
manners that Islam taught us be gentle
be nice p and all of us i'm d'lai it's a
common sense it's common sense so
anything you see you hear about the
religion doesn't make any sense to use
of comments as asked and basically
unleash Allah it will be explained to
you we before we go to break tell us
right now I mean the person obviously
when you come to Islam you know many
people who come to us and they
appreciate Islam more than people who
are even brought up in with some phantom
solution you know so now you know they
come to the mush it and and they take
that first step the declaration of faith
that there's no guy but the One God
Muhammad is the Messenger and now they
kind of get over what they're excited to
get the hugs and kisses and now they
come home everybody's given him a book
and they got about 50 books and you know
this person's telling look do this roll
your pants up this person tell him a cut
off with the girlfriend has been put
through the mists walk in his mouth and
he's like you know it
cited but kind of overwhelmed so when we
get back can you tell us how he can
balance this out so he don't break
absolutely how's that I'll be right back
and the Sheikh answer this question here
in the D show but you figure out that
young man has have a purpose if you were
to take away mosquitoes from the planet
within a few months everything dies let
me just took away with the mosquito and
the scale is a fact it's a fact
mosquitoes mosquitoes but if you take
away mankind nothing happens so this
whole ecosystem this whole wheel this
whole cycle does it need you so why are
you here back here on the D show with
dr. Sheikh waliba Sunni given some
advice to the new Muslims our brothers
in faith who have made that conscious
decision to worship none other but the
creator of the heavens and the earth
Allah so now they're kind of overwhelmed
all right they're excited they meet all
their brothers took the Shahada and now
they got like 50 books everyone's
telling them do this do that they got
you know all the shakes in the moisture
now everybody out of the love people
have good intention but sometimes you
know people can overwhelm someone give
them too much weight to push we don't
want the person is too great so what
advice do you give any situation my
advice is basically to sit your
priorities straight when it comes to
learning the religion and I'm practicing
it there is something called peller's
there is something of fundamental issue
principle of faith the article of faith
these are the one that you have to start
with and basically the print that the
pillars of Islam these are the thing
that you start with our Allah Allah Anna
said if the first thing a lot revealed
on Quran don't drink don't further Kate
and do this and do that no one will quit
fern occasion no one will start with
bright but the first thing was the
reveal is to have that love for a la
spinetta it's to have that faith in
Allah is to trust Allah is to fear a la
spinetta is to think about the day of
judgement to know that you will be
standing before a la one day and you
will ask you about your deeds about what
you have done in this world you lie
more establish this foundation you put
these thick layers in your heart this
belief that when you are ready to go to
that next step to go into these details
and they said earlier step by step the
most important thing the pillars of
Islam stick to it do it when you
establish it when you have it basically
down masha'Allah you are doing it very
well go to the next level which is the
extra prayer the extra volunteers and
here i want to tell you something don't
get confused see someone who has
knowledge who knows of his righteousness
and let him basically your mentor you
somebody that he can help you break this
down to you consult him but if you start
basically every person a person Muslim
tell you something you might get
confused and you might also get wrong
information because unfortunately a lot
of Muslim they don't differentiate
between culture and religion so the
introduced maybe to you certain cultures
as if it's part of the religion I know
this guy this brother in Colorado he
mashallah became Muslim they took him
downstairs they took off his suit and
they said it's all change your clothes
now you have to err Muslim clothes and
they put on him like a Syrah or a pens
with a long shirt en el like this which
is usually dress in certain countries
yeah haruka whatever they call it and
I'm basically they put socks on him and
choose and everything was new and
everything different color you can
imagine and put a kufi and put girl in
his eyes I'm serious one in his eye go
ahead lucky and I was that it's a
certain like it's a blood like a mask or
a kind now yeah yes some people do that
its cultural it's a cultural yeah thing
and it may be the process undo it but
also it's part of his culture so he went
back to his wife he knocked on the door
and his wife when she saw him she
thought that this is maybe a guy from
Paula bond or something and she called
the police and he said all that I mean
she opened the door imagine your husband
went to work or the suit and coming back
with
deeply different clothes from a
different culture and he said what
happened to you and he said I became
Muslim said what is that what Muslim
Islam is about is about the clause about
just changing your your clothes I think
this is this is just an example of how
sometimes our community they behave in a
wrong way with the new Muslims I want
them to look like me or my culture or to
eat like me you know what something big
about this religion this really does not
strip you from your culture if you are
Latinos if you are african-american if
you're a white American if you are
whatever Chinese whatever your culture
coming from Islam does not strip you
from culture you stay with the culture
they did but the only different the slum
put guidelines to control this culture
so if you cross the line and you do
something Haram stop the sculpture stop
you you cannot do it you cannot being
part of the Cross does not justify it
but other than that it's up to you that
we address the way you eat the way you
live your life as long as you follow the
guidelines of the religion so you
emphasize getting to really know the
basics that's where it starts the five
pillars of Islam and slowly building
from there yes and then we talked about
the culture anything that's good in the
cult good food maybe even good dress but
long as his modest dress you know you're
not showing what is considered immodest
in Islam you'd like either fell out of
the dress that can be different from one
culture to another yeah okay and
becoming a new Muslim one who submitted
his will to the creditor happens in her
you don't now like this situation have
to put on a thumb and change your name
all of a sudden no it's not because this
is prevalent this happens a lot yeah
it's have been important but you don't
need to do that at all there is nothing
called Islamic laws it means our clothes
that cover your I would cover the your
private part that if you're a male or a
female to cover her body that's what
Islamic laws me this is not to wear this
though but doesn't wear Kofi it doesn't
it just not to do with that yeah you can
wear whatever clothes that you want to
ever food that you want to drink
whatever language you use every name
that you have the Prophet SAW solemn so
many people became Muslim you never
order them to change their names and
some of their names are not Arabic names
it could be for example cell
and Alpharetta see a purging would not a
Muslim country at that time a roomie so
hype is Romans from from basically
Europe he didn't ask him to change his
name because it's not and I'm Muslim
there's no such things call Muslim name
there's no such thing is like a Muslim
name no any any name which is has a
meaning or whatever it's a Muslim need
the only now I on Islamic names if these
names will have a wrong meaning in a
snap like somebody called himself God
that's an Islamic not acceptable yeah or
somebody call himself on the slave of
Sean so so if it has some pagan origins
or some ass then you will be here if
your name is Mike if your name is Tom
you keep your name you don't have to
change the look and you can continue to
dress in your suit and tie you don't
have to throw on the thobe or anything
like that now at all okay i'm sure many
muslims are learning this is important
for them because you know they have this
misconception this notion also and also
a lot of people became Muslims you know
new muslims in the time of the Prophet
Muhammad Saleh they always went back to
the family the arrows became part of
their family and I noticed some of the
new Muslim the moment they became Muslim
they have nothing to do with their
family with their people with their
basically they're the people from the
same and be culture that they belong to
they feel that Islam encourage you not
to be any more have a relationship with
your mom of your family or you know
that's absolutely wrong that's wrong
tone absolutely this time encourage you
to be better basically son better
daughter better husband better a
basically father and mother and uncles
and so forth so you have something so
beautiful don't shy away from people go
to them and basically it shared them the
advice that you the beautiful thing that
you have if you think yourself under a
pressure if you go to us maybe some
family member you're afraid that this is
will maybe take you away from the Dean
you cannot face these challenges in this
case you know what I would advise you to
strengthen your amann first and you
go back to your fate basically to face
these challenges future one more thing
which is make sure that you hang out
with good people friends is a very
important element if you're surviving
actually in this religion make sure that
you surround yourself with good Muslims
that people will educate you care about
you take you step by step and they will
not take you to an extreme path because
this religion has love to would be
extreme or they will make you just teach
you certain culture which is maybe it's
not part of your own culture yeah with
that say we're going to take a break and
get some more beautiful advice when we
come back here on a Dean show sit tight
one God wish him alone do what he wants
you to do put your desire is this thing
inside you that just wants this and
wants that and you just can't get enough
you know what you never get enough until
the dirts in your mouth don't let it
come to that be sincere and honest as
the one who created you to guide race
the first step put off chasing all the
women and the good times and the parties
and this and that there is no one would
be a voice ship except Allah don't wait
you never know if this would come today
for you or back here on the Dean show
and we're giving some beautiful advice
to the numa Sims now I mentioned early
before I go to my next question I said
look look we're following the same way
of life is all the profit and I said
that look Jesus was a Muslim Abraham was
a Muslim am i lying here no I don't
actually by being Muslim you just in the
same path of all these prophets and
messengers that were sent before
Muhammad's assalam I mean what do you
think Abraham used to tell people to do
believe in what one going to leave in
one car and I'm his messenger what do
you think Noah was saying is people what
eating all these prophets were were
doing the same thing that the Prophet
Muhammad it was signed worship Allah
alone and basically I'm his messenger
that's why the Prophet said pull mccune
to be there I'm in a row so I'm not
something new I'm just similar to all
these prophets and messengers before me
and it is that jesus also peace be upon
him also stayed the same thing he said
or
shipped on the creator of the heavens
and earth and I'm his messenger to you
they never call people to worship
themselves no idols icons saying statues
none of these things right no okay this
is a fact not fiction you're getting
here on the Dean show now our
responsibility as a community when
someone embraces the same way of life of
all the messengers Islam how should we
help these people that's very good point
actually for us as a muscle community
especially in the in the West when we
when we see somebody accept Islam and
declare his Shahada domestic so many
times is Allah Akbar we give him a hug
and debt and that's about it and believe
it or not those brothers and sisters who
became Muslims they need a lot of
support a lot of Education to be provide
the Prophet SAW Sullum after a five the
city of a pipe accepted Islam there is
about 200 people accepted Islam from it
the prophetess I'll have assigned for
each one of them for each one of them
someone to teach them the religion to
teach them the religion so what you need
to do with somebody became Muslim we
make sure that we follow up with this
brother but the sister there is someone
in the community willing to take them
step-by-step teach them how to pray out
to make although in the correct why
according to the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu arias our lab we must provide
also a lot of counseling for them so
many of the brother and sisters who
became Muslim they came from lot of
struggle or psychological maybe problems
financial problems social problems and
and they found in Islam answer to this
problem but still this is the
theoretical part of it the practical
part is upon us as Muslim to provide a
practical solution for their problems
for the challenge that that they facing
that we must provide these services to
them and not to neglect their rights
upon us as a Muslim community it's
enough to be happy to make dua for them
to give him a hug and after that what
who's going to basically help this
brothers if he was kicked out of his
house or the sister if she was kicked
out of her house because she's
so she put a job who's going to help him
if he couldn't have if you couldn't
survive financially because he just
became Muslims I'm not suggesting that
it has became a completely well for a
kind of system we provide help but we
help them to stand on their feet to know
that we are brothers and sisters and and
we mean that that we really we stand
beside them and help them provide the
advice the companionship them and their
family so many of the so many new
Muslims told me chef I have no family
anymore no friends I'm just like new and
I need to see that support from the
community and I agree with them also one
thing I noticed sometimes a new Muslim
comes to us we kind of have some of
Muslim and I think this very rude it is
they stare at them and one of them
common complaint from New Muslims they
said a lot of time they stare like we
look at us they're ours it smiled to
your new Muslim brothers go ahead and
ask and how can I help you please if you
need any help let me know it's my phone
number that's what I do sometimes you
don't need to stare and look and not
reacting even some people really
suspicious about those who became in new
Muslim this is Shane this is really
shame that to see incident like this one
of the things that also I hear a lot
about from New Muslims that when they
come to Islam they said you know what we
left whatever religion we had because
the most interesting thing in this
religion its authenticity that it's
authentic religion has a very clear
sources very reliable sources just quran
and sunnah preserved protected so when
we became muslim we come across all
these people everybody give me an
opinion ever give me this amigo you know
do this not to do that I mean please
don't confuse them provide for them what
is really in the Quran and Sunnah don't
provide them what culture you are
familiar or what you think is good i
remember one this sister she became
muslim and she said i was giving a shot
so this old lady came and also then she
came in front of everybody
and she gives the most after her she
said Krista must have because you became
Muslim and the poor lady knew you Muslim
she gets scared she kissed them was up
this is three times it's like hold on
auntie were when he got this from there
is nothing in the Quran it's and kiss
the nose says some people they are so
excited maybe and they don't basically
realize that I'm introducing something
it's not on the Quran ism do you know
that this is the process of them did and
finally also we have to understand new
Muslims you make mistakes did not get a
pair pray perfectly like you you're not
going to make without like the one
sister she's a new Muslim she came and
she is not wearing a long claws or
proper cross for the salat he can
imagine somebody pulled her out of the
line I said hey you cannot pray like
this so I'm sorry I just became Muslim
right before I saw prayer and I don't
know what to do so sometimes the Muslim
community have to know you know what you
got any more in Arab country or in the
subcontinent or where you pray in your
locality and it may be never sewn you
Muslim ever you're living in a society
or hamdullah every day there's somebody
accepting Islam so open up for them be
tolerant don't be mean you know mistakes
will happen finally this guy was prank
and that's a lot and he his phone rings
so he pick up the phone and said honey
I'll call you right back is a lot side
of the circu you know I have that we
told you no you can't do that in the
form but don't be mad because the he
doesn't know yeah you know just just
relax take it easy smile give support
you know and and the end of the day I'll
tell those brothers who became Muslims
you didn't became Muslim for me or for
my community of anybody's community you
only became Muslim for him for the
Almighty Allah soprano time that's it if
people want to get a hold of you if they
have some more questions there are new
Muslims and they need some more guidance
what website do you recommend that
people can visit for some of the
questions that they might have you can
either go to another lab forum or if you
have a question listed to religious
stuff like that you go to MJ online
shake thank you very much more come as a
beautiful advice may god almighty allah
reward
thank you thank you and some great
advice for our new Muslim brothers and
sisters who accepted the way of all the
messengers Islam that complete and total
submission to the one who created you
and that's how you get that piece and
some great advice focus on the basics
the basis establish a direct connection
like you have with the creator of the
heavens in the earth the prayer five
times a day there's a cat the five
pillars that he discussed be around good
people and you can get some more
information here at this number 1 866 to
Islam we also have some people who are
there to help guide you along the way
it's been set up for those people who
want to accept Islam and those people
who have accept Islam you can call us
and we can hope and will help to get you
along the way to continue to rest the
journey and continue to also tune in to
the D show we'll see you next time until
then peace be unto you